Film Courage: I want to go back….you got
the script to Rock in a Hard Place (Editor’s
Note: the set where this interview is taking
place), you came on set, James Cullen Bressack:
…… He saved our a$s is what happened!
Sheldon A. Smith:…..The director, James!
Great working with you.
James: He literally got the script like
two minutes before…
I gotta get back to work…He got the script
two minutes before coming on set.
We had to cast him last minute because somebody
fell out and he ‘killed it!’
He did a great job.
He saved us.
Sheldon: Thank you.
I was rehearsing as I was getting dressed
with Patrick.
I was rehearsing with the lead actor (Patrick
Muldoon) as I was getting dressed and he was
like ‘Man, you already know the dialogue?’
and I was like ‘Yeah, I’m trying to pick
it up’ as I get dressed and go to make-up…I
was crazy.
They literally just through me in there and
the next thing I know, I’m doing a scene.
That’s every actor’s dream.
Film Courage: And you said it had been six
months since you’d been in Straight Outta
Compton?
Sheldon: Well….no.
I shot Straight Outta Compton in August 2014,
so a year.
Film Courage: A year?
And you hadn’t booked anything since?
Sheldon: I hadn’t booked anything.
Film Courage: And this (role) came about
just like that and it was like this is your
moment.
So when you were taking a Lyft over from wherever
you were staying, what was going through your
head?
Were you nervous?
Sheldon: No.
I wasn’t nervous.
At first I was thinking like, alright this
pilot probably isn’t anything if someone
is going to just drop out and not show up.
But I’m going to go because I’m an actor
and I love acting and they’re paying me….so
I’m going to go.
And when I got to the set, I was like ‘Oh,
this is the real deal!’
(Laughs) Then I got the jitters and the butterflies
but then I thought about my coach, Bobby Chance
and you guys have probably seen her work,
you probably know Bobby Chance.
She always tells me just to be a Barracuda,
what ever it is, just pick it up and play.
Have fun.
Don’t let the dialogue or anything distract
you.
Just have fun.
That’s what I did.
I thought D Major was a fun character and
I was like ‘Oh, this a dream come true.‘
It’s been a great experience these past
few days.
Film Courage: That’s interesting….be
a Barracuda.
What is that exactly?
You said just have fun but is there also an
aggressive side to it where you need to just
attack things and go after what you want?
Sheldon: Yeah… you’ve got to just attack
it.
You’ve got to put your teeth into it, get
a nice grip, and hold on tight.
And that is just exactly what I did with this
role.
I put my teeth into it and held on tight.
Question for the viewers: What tools or tricks
can an actor use to develop a character quickly?